طبعا دعينا نبدا بالحصيله حقيقه الامر
وعلى ما يبدو اننا نتحدث بكل اتصال
بارتفاع العدد بالعشرات حتى اللحظه المؤكد
هو اكثر من 760 على الاقل 762 وفي مناطق
النظام مناطق
المعارضه لان الوضع كارثي وكارثي بامتياز
وحتى اللحظه التحديث هذا الجديد في مناطق
سيره النظام يرتفع
يعني حسب المعطيات حسب المعلومات ان العدد
قد يصل الى 1000 وما يزيد من الخسائر
البشريه كيف يواجهون شاهدنا المواجهه
بمزيد من الخسائر البشريه شاهدنا المواجهه
بمزيد من التشرد في الشوارع خوفا من هزات
ارتداديه بعد الهزه الارتداديه التي كانت
بعض الصور اليوم اي انها يعني المواطن
السوري الان في تلك المناطق لا يعلم اين
يذهب هل سيذهب الى داخل بعض المباني ان
يبقى في الشارع تحت الامطار في ظل الظروف
الجويه القافيه وايضا من هم تحت الانقاذ
الان يعني هل هم سيبكون تحت الانقاذ الى
ان يتمكن احد من انقاذهم ام هؤلاء سيكون
مصيرهم الموت دون ان يتمكن اي شخص
بالانقاذهم واقراصهم من تحت انقاذ هذه
المباني المهدمه